thinking about the table as a physical
ball that's festive
table and that's made of atoms and
molecules at the same time it's exactly
what you're not supposed to do okay and
Yellin so you shouldn't be surprised
that it's hard to do it I'm not sure if
we have yet on the table they proposed
criteria in a demarcation cry tears or
what is real and what is not real but my
hope mine would be that something is
real and it forms a important part of a
useful way of talking about the actual
world so the present King of France so
reality is contingent on utility well uh
our description of reality is contingent
on utility at the very least so you I
certainly could imagine talking about
reality in a way that never referred to
the concept of the Constitution of the
United States and would not be mistaken
in any way I could just list all the
fermions and bosons and have them of all
the worthies prettier equation I would
not be wrong I'll be missing something
really interesting and I can't come up
with a better word than useful I
couldn't talk about the atoms in this
molecules and this atmosphere in our
room right now atom by atom kinetic
theory I would be missing the
opportunity to describe some very useful
regularities about the behavior of the
atmosphere of this room in terms of
pressure and density and the laws of
thermodynamics and also I have no right
to think that the description in terms
of atoms are fermions and bosons is the
bottom one right I mean it should be and
I don't want yet the reality of the
atoms to depend on one year I'm talking
about it so I think that all the
different levels in which we can talk
about things will beat this to death
this afternoon I have a claim to reality
that is essentially really strong
religious people will say that the
notion of God is an important part well
good and Stephen said cars real in
effect right because every time we
haven't even define that for this
congress let me give you a way to think
about and the question seems to me that
would come up from this is let's imagine
that this you
goes viral and all the fundamentalists
in this country listen to it and buy
your story completely and burned down
their churches okay my point is the
meaning of what you just said the
meaning of all of this does it's not the
sounds that were produced it's the
meaning of it and it caused physical
things to change in the world
radical major restructuring of the
matter of the face of viewers now in
that sense I would say that the meaning
is real the meaning has causal efficacy
physical causal efficacy but the meaning
is going to be something that's not the
sounds it's not the movement of neurons
it's something else and we haven't got a
good way of talking about it yet in fact
and the story I want to say is that I
think just like we can't say that
physics is bottomed out certainly as an
evolutionary biologist I would say that
our understanding of evolution isn't a
bombed-out there's a lot of processes
there that we don't fully understand yet
and the more we've pursued it the more
we realized that Darwin's story is in
effect its agnostic about mechanism
there's huge amounts of mechanistic
stuff we've discovered that are making
it a more complex story if that's your
story about the brain level isn't it
possible that vast amount of new
information is going to come out about
how the brain does it its job using
complexity and and various ways of
talking about this process that don't
look quite as simple as we've just
talked about my suspicion is that we'll
eventually call this teleology it's not
the kind of Cartesian teleology or the
kind of god teleology
um but it's it's the real teleology that
got me here that is I wanted to come
here and chat with you guys listen to it
that's the real teleology as far as I'm
concerned it's the same kind of
teleology that's driving this story that
I just told about you know
fundamentalism it's real it makes a
difference in the world we just haven't
come up with a good way to explain it
and I'm not convinced that we're ever
going to do it by just saying it's
quarks and gluons
you